hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his dialogue
the credo named after the main
interlocutor of the dialogue with
Socrates Plato has that character
provides some arguments for a position
that that he's advancing in relation to
Socrates trial Socrates impending
execution and the possibility of escape
credo is a rich man from out of town
and he is a student of Socrates and also
a friend and so he comes in and he says
look I've bribed the jailer we have the
escape plan in place you just have to
come with us and Socrates says to him
well you know let's let's think about
this so credo is trying to convince
Socrates that it's the right thing to do
and I've put it here on the board
the main arguments that created is
advancing you notice that he doesn't
just have one single point that he just
harps on over and over again although
there is going to be a common thread
running through all of these and we're
going to look at Socrates response to
that in some of the other core concept
videos about this so credo wants to get
Socrates to leave Athens this is his
main point Socrates should flee Athens
he's been sentenced to death the trial
was you know rather unfair and Socrates
said look
going to get a good trial from you so
I'm going to use this as a a talking
point piece you had your chance
Athens that's all discussed in the
apology so credo says look Socrates you
should leave now
now remember Socrates is an old man he's
lived in Athens all of his life except
for being on military campaigns credo is
a rich man from another Greek city-state
Thessaly in this case and credo is going
to make some some arguments so the first
argument that he makes is an
interestingly says look your death is
going to be a great loss to me you're
the kind of friend that I can't easily
replace and what does he mean by that he
means not that while you're a rich
friend or your well-connected or
anything like that because Socrates
isn't instead what he means is you're
somebody who has integrity you're
somebody who is reflective you're
somebody who can teach you really
one-of-a-kind Socrates and I don't want
to lose you so that's an interesting
argument and you know you would think
that credo could just stick with that
but instead he moves on immediately to
and besides what are people going to
think
Here I am a rich guy we've got other
friends that are rich as well and we
would put ourselves out for just about
anybody are they going to say they
really didn't like Socrates they must
not have cared for him because they
valued their wealth more than they
valued the opportunity to bribe the
jailor and get him out of jail now
notice that that's making the assumption
on the part of those people that given
the opportunity Socrates will go along
with it socrates isn't going to go along
with it
and that's one of the weaknesses to to
credos position and we're going to come
back to this people will think thing in
a few minutes another argument that he
gives he says look the plan is ready so
this is an argument for what from what
we might call expediency or or active
ability he's saying I've already bribed
the jailer we've already got the escape
plan ready don't worry about us you know
the people of Athens are not going to be
able to hurt us they're not going to be
able to to attack our reputation if we
get you out of here we're going to be in
another Greek city-state and we'll be
okay and none of your friends here are
going to suffer because of it so that's
a third argument being given the fourth
which is the most interesting the one
that's going to be the sticking point
that's going to get Socrates reframing
the argument Cretan goes on and he says
oh by the way it's wrong for you to stay
here and allow yourself to be executed
morally wrong not just it's it's
imprudent or not profitable or a bad
idea not just people are going to say
stuff about us not just it's going to be
you know real lost to me and to other
people who love you but Socrates you're
doing the wrong thing by actually
staying here and plate or Plato has
credo give three different reasons for
this one is this is a very interesting
one look Socrates if you stay here
you're doing exactly what your enemies
intended there they wanted to silence
you they wanted to silence you for a
long time now they're finally going to
get the chance and you're playing right
into their hands so you're doing
something wrong why because you're
collaborating with somebody else who's
trying to do something wrong
namely to you so that's one another very
interesting argument Socrates you have
children if you allow yourself to be
executed who's going to look after your
kids and you know nowadays you might say
well you know your family structure
or worse the orphanage or Child
Protective Services or somebody will
step in and take care of them but you
know in ancient societies to be an
orphan was really to be at a
disadvantage so by allowing these other
people and the legal system to in effect
cause his death he is putting his sons
his young not yet developed you know not
yet fully educated sons at risk and
that's wrong for him to do he's being a
bad father by not fleeing to - you know
some other place where presumably his
sons could join him or he could send
money to his sons the last one that he
says and here credo kind of shifts
ground and it comes back to this this
second point he says look Socrates you
know you're this guy who's always
talking about the need to be good and
about bravery and this is not the act of
a brave man just to you know accept it
and allow these people to kill you you
should you know you should go and try to
do everything you can you should you
know he's not obviously in the 19th or
20th century or 21st century so he can't
say rage rage against the dying of the
light but in effect he's saying
something very similar Socrates you
can't take this lying down because
that's the that's an act of cowardice
almost immediately
credo shifts to say and people are going
to think that we're a bunch of cowards
too because we didn't help you out and
you know what we are helping you out and
you're not cooperating with us and all
of that goes back to is people will
thank and bring about public perception
public reputation public image rather
than worrying about what the actualities
of acts of the case really are credo is
recurring to saying look you know most
people are going to just say these guys
were too cowardly they didn't have the
guts to
try this daring maneuver and get
Socrates out of prison so he's you know
making a pretty strong case for this
idea that Socrates should flee Athens he
should break the rules
he should violate the laws of his city
which him under which he's been found
guilty and he's been sentenced to death